being as a company is you know
bootstrapping we're looking for a really
good talented developer and you know for
a CTO type position and I'm just
wondering you know obviously I can't
compete with Google in terms of how much
I can pay pay somebody what can I do to
entice top-level talent to join my team
fantastic great question so why do
top-level Talent join teams if you're
talking about top-level talent they have
their choice of where to work so as an
example they will vector on two things
one is the opportunity right which means
competition compensation equity stock
etc but then they're also going to think
about the mission of the company they
may also think about lifestyle so those
are actually three I would argue three
different vectors so Google and Facebook
are going to pay an extremely large
amount of money and they'll always beat
you incompetent in compensation that
being said you would be compensated to
sell your soul to make people click on
ads 0.001 percent more and you'll spend
12 hours a day trying to get people to
click on ads just a little bit more and
collect more data about them and do more
creepy [ __ ] over at Facebook that makes
you want to kill yourself and so the
purpose that the person would have there
would be zero would be like a zero on 10
zero of 10 in terms of like how
meaningful and purposeful this work is
going to work for Facebook in 2019
you're just going there to make the ad
network work better and you know invade
people's privacy more it's a zero of 10
it's literally anybody who's there is
there for the compensation period now
kind of startup hey listen maybe you're
a six or seven in terms of total comp
but on mission oh it's calm calm and I'm
really into mindfulness
oh it's cafe X and I love robotics and
coffee
oh it's fit bod I am a CrossFit junkie
oh it's steezy
I am into dance I would love to work on
a dance start
so when you can align the person's
personal interest and then you can you
can beat Facebook and Google where
developers will want to kill themselves
working there and then you could add to
it lifestyle you could say to the
developer how do you like to work do you
like to work from home are you a remote
person on your night person your weekend
person how do you like to work maybe we
can be more flexible in that range and
then you just have to find somebody at
the point in life where they've made
enough money and maybe you can beat
people on lifestyle and on purpose now
you're selling filters air filters that
may not be the most purposeful work to
people so you may need to expand that
mission and say hey what we really want
to do is help people be healthier and
make the world you know have cleaner air
and make people not get sick from that
kind of stuff you can kind of up level
the level up the mission of the company
so I think that's something you can work
on if you expand the mission like hey we
right now we work on replacing people's
filters and their HVAC units because
that's making people sick but we also
want to develop new products and new
services that keep people healthy and
let them know their air quality I know
that you have some other ideas around
that so I'd sell them on that
overarching mission and you can sell
them on lifestyle and on opportunity hey
listen you can give them extraordinary
equity compensation and moderate too
modest to moderate equity comp what you
want to look for is somebody who doesn't
want to be part of the big industrial
advertising complex you want to somebody
who wants to be part of a small team and
build something exciting and make it fun
and exciting to work for you I make it
fun and exciting to work at launch or I
try to buy we travel the world we go on
scuba diving trips we have fun we go to
dinner as we go to nap but I just try to
keep it light and breezy and fun but
there is a sense of mission and purpose
here and that's why I'm able to land
high quality people because yeah it's
kind of dope to be helping founders
realize their vision right so I have
this incredible advantage with the
mission so that's where you can really I
think differentiate yourself and your
level of passion for it so are you
writing blog posts are
you you know out there banging the drum
about the mission and can you connect
with people on social media social
networks you know LinkedIn interacting
with people at events and get somebody
roped into the excitement about the
missus hey we bootstrapped this business
to this level and if we can get to this
next level we can start releasing these
products and then we can raise venture
capital we can go big just tell that
story tell it candidly and it's a
numbers game as well you're gonna talk
to a hundred developers and 80 of them
are gonna be like I'm here for max
conversation you just eliminate them
they're mercenary and then you focus on
the 20% that might be missionary people
who want to see the product manifest
itself in the world they want to see the
problem solved in the world that's what
you need is missionary type people and
you can win them on lifestyle and you
might be able to also win them based on
the mission of the company is that
helpful very much so I appreciate it
thank you okay I'll see you when you're
back in San Francisco and keep me on
updates at launch Co update me and your
monthly update I'm watching your revenue
I'm watching your traction you're on the
radar right you got it
all right looking forward to next time
you're talking about five years